prime minister Gaga lost the president
of European commissioner Ursula from The
Lion and the Secretary General of NATO
and stoltenberg have just concluded
their trilateral meeting and will
deliver short remarks after that it is
possible for medium to ask questions the
press conference is in English with
simultaneous translation into Estonian
first prime minister Gaga's the floor is
yours
many of you here today as it is our
Independence Day tyrions Jerusalem I'm
so glad that you accepted my invitation
to join us here on our independence day
and when we celebrate ours
105th anniversary of of Estonia this
means a lot to me and it also means a
lot to Estonian people so thank you for
being here let me start by sharing a
thought by diasides the secret to
happiness is freedom and the secret to
Freedom is courage
Estonia had the courage to fight for our
freedom the same applies to our
Ukrainian friends
their Fight For Freedom today is a
reminder that freedom is not given and
it needs constant care Freedom also
needs friends and partners
31 years ago when Estonia restored its
independence after the Soviet occupation
we set as our foreign and defense policy
motto we are never alone again
Ursula your presence here today is its
embodiment Estonia is a proud member of
European union and NATO
NATO and the European Union are the
cornerstones of not only our freedom and
security but that of the whole Europe
gray areas however create instability
and lead to lead to war they must be
become the thing in the past that is why
Ukraine's place is in the European Union
and after the end of the war also in
NATO
four estonians the 24th of February has
always been about celebrating Freedom we
know that freedom comes at a price you
need to fight for it
a light presence here in Estonia
contributes every day to the security of
our country and the alliance as a whole
but Estonia takes its own part of the
burden increasingly seriously we have
been significantly boosting our defense
spending it's nearly three percent now
the will of the Estonian people to
defend our country is unwavering the
number of volunteers who wish to
contribute to National Defense has
considerably increased
today ukrainians are showing
unprecedented courage and commitment in
defending their country
the Free World needs to show the same
courage and support to Ukraine until the
last Russian soldier has left Ukraine
Ukraine must win and the aggressor must
push must be pushed back
for this we must also believe in
Ukraine's Victory Ukraine needs enough
weapons and ammunition to win the war
uh that is why I propose that EU member
states jointly procure ammunition for
Ukraine during the pandemic we were able
to react quickly to jointly procure
vaccines let us act quickly now and send
more ammunition to Ukraine we must keep
in mind that the threat Russia poses is
a long-term one in addition to the
conventional War they are also waging a
hybrid War to create chaos and divide us
all European countries need to invest
more in their own defense and resilience
we cannot be afraid of Russian Terror
tactics if we fall for Russia's threats
we will wake up in much more dangerous
world
Ukraine and Russia's other neighbors are
not afraid so why should those countries
who are further from Ukraine be afraid
the way this war against Ukraine ends
will Define peace for generations to
come for any peace to us there needs to
be accountability Russian crimes against
Ukraine and its people must not go
unpunished and no Russian leader can be
immune from responsibility as team
Europe and team NATO we have shown
significant unity and resolve over the
past year
looking ahead these are keywords we must
take with us courage belief
accountability and leave no room for
fear thank you
thank you the president of the European
commission also from The Lion please
thank you prime minister
special day indeed the day when 105
years ago Estonia declared its
independence
estonia's determination to remain a free
and independent country has been put to
the test time and again
but Independence was finally restored on
the 20th of August 1991.
and I also want to share a thought or
quote of a famous Estonian the former
president Leonard Mary who said
Europe is not geography
Europe is a Unity of principles
and an allegiance to principles
principles shape geography
geography does not shape principles end
of quote and this is a truth that Putin
has never understood
one year on from the start of his brutal
War
Putin has failed to achieve a single one
of his strategic goals
instead of dividing the European Union
he finds US United and determined to
stand by Ukraine for as long as it takes
instead of dominating the global energy
Market
he has seen his main source of Revenue
slashed
instead of wiping Ukraine from the map
he is confronted with a nation more
vigorous than ever
Ukraine has become a testament to The
Bravery of a nation which will never
relent in its quest for freedom
we have seen that in every single day of
the 365 days since the beginning of this
atrocious War
and just as Estonia stands proudly as a
free and independent state Ukraine will
prevail
you can will prevail because ukrainians
will never neither Flinch nor step back
and Ukraine will prevail because Europe
and its partners and allies will stand
firm
but when you're on the fight rages on
and Putin has upped the stakes
he is sending hundreds of thousands of
young Russians as Canon fodder in the
trenches in Ukraine
what we saw and heard earlier this week
from Moscow
tells us that as the losses mount on the
battlefield
so does the desperation the delusion and
the disinformation
and that shows the strain Putin's regime
is under
but it also comes with real and renewed
danger for Ukraine so now is the time to
Double Down
we must keep giving Ukraine the means to
defend itself
until the Russians end this war and
leave Ukraine
and this is why we stand firmly by
Ukraine as determined as ever
to support Ukraine financially
economically and militarily
to increase our own defense capabilities
and to increase the pressure on Russia
and hold it accountable
Russia is increasingly isolated
I think very telling Was the vote
yesterday in the United Nations 141
countries
that voted in favor of the resolution
condemning Russia
Russia is falling backwards towards an
Antarctic economy cut away from the
world
our sanctions are eroding sharply its
economic base
slashing any Prospect to modernize it
we will continue to put pressure on
Russia and on those supporting it on the
battlefield
we will continue going after Putin's
cronies
and we will go after those helping
Russia
to circumvent sanctions or replenish its
war arsenal
same time we work to ensure Ukraine's
economic and Military resilience
first with continued financial support
67 billion euros we mobilized so far
second with increased Military Support
we aim to train 30 000 Ukrainian
soldiers in the European Union
Our member states are delivering
military equipment
and we will turn to Joint procurement
to deliver
urgent military supplies for Ukraine
such as 155 millimeter ammunition
equally important is to work with our
defense industry to ramp up the
production of this ammunition and other
equipment needed by Ukrainian forces but
also to replenish our own stocks
and diakaya you rightly so brought
attention to this at the last European
Council and we are taking action
finally
this is not just about winning on the
battlefield
ukrainians are fighting for their right
to choose their own future
and they have already chosen
they have chosen the European Union
they have chosen the unity of principles
as president Leonard Mary said
the Ukrainian soldiers fighting in the
trenches of bahut are defending this
Unity of principles
and in these dark times
the hearts of Ukrainian people are
warmed
by the confidence
that Ukraine will join the European
Union One Day
this is how principles shape geography
today I am proud to stand here together
with you and Julians in Italian
celebrating estaneous estonia's freedom
and Independence
and I'm proud that we stand here
together in support of the Ukrainian
people
and their fight for freedom and
Independence
I am certain that like the people of
Estonia Ukraine too will prevail thank
you
thank you NATO Secretary General and
stoltenberg please
congratulations on estonia's
Independence Day and uh
president
it's a honor to be together with both
you here in Thailand today on this very
symbolic day
over a hundred years ago Estonian troops
fought bravely for their freedom and
Independence
Independence was short-lived but
Estonian people never gave up
and with the fall of the Iron Curtain
you we gained your freedom and thank you
so much for inviting me to be part of
the celebrations today the Vlog the flag
Rising ceremony and the wreath playing
ceremony was really moving and it
demonstrates how much you value your
freedom
your history is a strong reminder that
we cannot take our freedom for granted
freedom is not for free we must fight
for it every day
today it is the Ukrainian people who are
bravely fighting for their freedom
and despite a dark year of Despair and
destruction their determination and
courage will no doubt prevail
one year ago President Putin launched
his full-fledged invasion of Ukraine
an illegal war or aggression
in blatant breach of basic and natural
rules
he wanted to break the will of the
Ukrainian people and he wanted to break
our Unity
President Putin failed Ukraine stands
and NATO and the EU stand with Ukraine
yet Putin has not given up his goals
he wants a different Europe where Russia
can dictate what neighbors do
he is not preparing for peace he is
preparing for more war
so we must give Ukraine what they need
to prevail
some worrying our support to Ukraine
risks triggering escalation
but there are no risk-free options and
the biggest risk of all
is if President Putin wins
because the message to him and other
authoritarian leaders would be that they
can use Force to get what they want
that will make the world more dangerous
and us more vulnerable
so supporting Ukraine
is not just morally the right thing to
do to do it is also in our own security
interest
that is why NATO allies are providing
unprecedented support to Ukraine working
hand in hand with the European Union
again Estonia is leading by example
providing more military aid as a share
of GDP than any other country
NATO presence protects the space for
allies to provide this support
since 2014 we have significantly
reinforced our presence and readiness
from the black to the Baltic Sea
including here in Estonia
NATO's multinational battle group in
topper led by the United Kingdom The
Thirst aggression
fighters from France and Germany help
protect your skies
a nations from Spain will augment your
air defenses
all these sends a clear message to
Moscow NATO will protect and defend
Estonia and every inch of Allied
territory
our article 5 commitment is iron plant
all for one
and one for all
and at our villain Summit in July will
take further steps to strengthen our
Collective defense
we also see progress as regards the
historic accession of Finland and Sweden
into our alliance two close neighbors of
Estonia
28 out of 30 allies have already
ratified accession protocols
I had good discussions with president
adirond in Ankara last week
we agreed to restart the talks and to
convene at rather meeting between
Finland Sweden and turkey at NATO
headquarters in mid-march under my
auspices
to discuss the implementation of the
agreement made last June and how to
complete the accession process
and it is good that the Hungarian
Parliament will start ratification
process next week
our aim is for both Finland and Sweden
to join us soon as possible
this will strengthen their security it
will strengthen Europe's security and it
will strengthen NATO
thank you once again for our exit
discussions are not least for your
strong commitment to the transatlantic
bond for North American Europe standing
together to protect our freedom thank
you
thank you now it's possible for me to
ask questions please do state your name
media Outlet you're representing and to
whom the question is addressed to please
use microphone which with my colleague
will assistant we have first ready there
please yes thank you for Public
Broadcasting questions to all of you
actually
um about China's position paper uh about
Ukraine and it has 12 points I would
like to know do you find it credible
especially as it um as the China
abstained United Nations vote yesterday
about Ukraine and also before the war
started U.S shared intelligent info
about Russia's troops and preparation so
has United States shared any info about
its claim made by Mr blink and that
China is considering giving weapons to
Russia thank you
so
um indeed the Chinese paper I think you
have to see the principles they shared
it's not a police plan but principles
that they shared you have to see them
against a specific backdrop
and that is the backdrop that China has
taken Side by signing for example an
unlimited friendship
uh right before the invasion Russia's
invasion in Ukraine started
so we will look at the principles of
course but we will look at them against
the backdrop that China has taken sites
on the question of supplies of military
support from China to Russia we have not
seen any actual delivery of lethal aid
but what we have seen
are signs and indications that China may
be planning and considering to supply a
military aid to Russia and China should
not do that because that will be to
support an illegal war or aggression
breaching international law and and
violating the U.N Charter and China is a
member of the U.N security Council and
they have a particular responsibility to
protect the U.N Charter and this is a
war regression violating uh exactly that
chartered
um then on the
the proposals uh under and and the
points presented by China uh so first of
all
China uh doesn't have much credibility
because uh they have not been able to
condemn uh the illegal invasion of
Ukraine and they also signed just days
before The Invasion uh an agreement
between President XI and President Putin
on
Limitless partnership with Russia
so I think what we see now in Ukraine uh
is that President Putin is not preparing
for war he's preparing for the exact
opposite for more war for more a new
offensives and therefore most likely
this war at some stage will end at the
negotiating table
but if we want a peaceful
solution we need to also realize that
what happens around that negotiating
table is totally dependent on the
strength and the situation on the
battlefield
so meaning that if you want a peaceful
negotiated solution where Ukraine
pervades as a sovereign independent
nation then we need to support Ukraine
military now because that's the only way
to create the conditions where President
Putin realized that he will not win on
the battlefield he has to sit down and
uh accept Ukraine as the independence of
a nation in uh in Europe so Military
Support today is the way to achieve a
peaceful agreement tomorrow
Yes actually I have
I have a to add because I always said
you and Charter is also something that
China is and should be respecting and it
says the principles of territorial
integrity and also the right to defend
one's country and and sovereignty so if
they are providing military
aid to uh aggressor then they go against
this U.N Charter and and that is
dangerous to the Peace of the world in
general thank you we have our next one
pradeep please my name is
I have one question to you the president
of the European commission and one
question to the Secretary General of the
NATO to the commission what measures
will you take to prevent the
circumvention of the European sanctions
by the third countries
and to the NATO Secretary General how
NATO will help Moldova to secure its
defense against Russia
so we are in our sanctioned packages we
are increasing the measures to make sure
that there are neither loopholes nor a
circumvention
we have a sanctions Envoy Davido
Sullivan who is traveling to different
third countries to reinforce
the message that any kind of
circumvention of sanctions will have
consequences for example we have
included in our sanctions packages the
possibility to list
persons or entities that are even from
certain countries that are circumventing
the sanctions by exporting goods from or
importing Goods to third countries from
the European Union and then bringing
them to Russia
um so here increasingly we are giving a
very clear message this this will not be
tolerated and this will have
consequences
of course we are concerned when we see
uh uh the challenges they face and
that's a diet consequence of the war in
Ukraine Moldova is a close and highly
valued partner of NATO we have been
working with them for many years we have
agreed now to step up our partnership
and also to help to build uh defense
capacity we have a tailored defense
capacity building
agreement in place
to help to strengthen their different
institutions and to help them to
strengthen their resilience we also
welcome of course efforts by individual
allies also know that the European Union
is doing it a lot to support Moldova
because I think if there's one lesson
that at least we can learn from the war
in Ukraine is the importance of
supporting those countries which are
vulnerable for Russian aggression as
soon as possible and and that also
applies for moldovan that's that's the
reason why I need to work a more closely
and provide more support
thank you next one please
from Delphi as you all know any positive
signal from these two large
multinational powers can serve as a
boost for morale for troops on the front
lines and an entire nation in suffering
so my question to president for the lion
would be Ukraine would like to begin
accession talks to the EU within this
year can you tell ukrainians what their
government can do to make that dream
happen and Secretary General stoltenberg
um
president zielinski is coming to the
Village Summit and Ukraine would like to
see a clear pathway to membership there
so what can the ukrainians do to make
that dream happen and I'd like the prime
minister's thoughts on that as well
thank you
yes the
so it's not a rigid time wise but it
depends on the candidate country and it
is amazing to see the determination of
Ukraine
to go through this thorough process but
at utmost speed
and
um already their step forward to apply
for becoming a candidate country they
had to do a lot and it was impressive to
see how they were delivering while
fighting a war it also shows the
functioning of the administration and
the highly digitized state of the
administration which is impressive
therefore it is of course in the hands
of Ukraine how they perform how they
reform how they improve uh the status of
their country with strong support from
the European Commission because this is
our task uh to advise and to support and
to help as much as possible on that
um so I can only say it is impressive to
see uh the the the strong will of
Ukraine to join the European Union uh
the willingness to reform thoroughly
their country and all this while
fighting an aggressor this is
outstanding it's in their hands we will
have as a process of oral presentation
of the progress in Spring to the member
states but more important is the report
in fall that summarizes for all
candidate countries in the accession
process their progress during the year
and I am confident that Ukraine will
excel in this report in the fall that
then will be presented to the member
states
I invited the president zielinski to
attend the NATO Summit in vilis in July
I really hope that they can be be there
in person but of course it depends on
the situation because in the mid-sover
full-fledged War invasion of this
country
NATO's position on membership for
Ukraine remains unchanged we have stated
several times that Ukraine will become a
member of the alliance at the same time
we all realize that the first step to
ensure that that will happen is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails as a
sovereign in the plant Nation without a
sovereign Democratic free Ukraine the
membership will not be an issue at all
so all our Focus all our efforts is now
on ensure that Ukraine prevails that
Putin doesn't win because then there
will be a no issue of a membership for
Ukraine
then when this war ends
then of course we need to ensure that
history doesn't repeat itself
because this is there is a pattern of
Russian aggression Georgia in 2008
in 2014 and then the full-fledged
Invasion uh last year
and we need to make sure that when the
war ends now that uh Russia is not able
to continue
to chip away at European security and we
need to break this cycle of Russian
aggression
this will be about enabling the
ukrainians to have strong Armed Forces
themselves so they can deter aggression
themselves but it will also be an issue
of creating the framework
and the under and uh
political framework that that sends a
clear message to Moscow that that
they're going to continue to attack an
independent Sovereign Democratic
neighbor Ukraine
so we need to help Ukraine move forward
on the Euro Atlantic path uh Ukraine is
part of the Euro Atlantic family and the
first step is to ensure that Ukraine
prevails as a Sovereign Nation to to add
to that gray areas are a source of
conflict and War and that's why NATO has
been the peace project we have to
believe in Ukraine and therefore we also
have to give military aid so that
Ukraine can defend themselves and and
then when the war is over then move on
with the open door policy of NATO
thank you next one please marisel run
for German public broadcaster are the
question to the Secretary General you
mentioned talks with um turkey how can
NATO act on on Turkey in order to speed
up Sweden's joining process
first of all this is a priority for NATO
and and for me and I'm confident that
both Finland and student will become
full members of The Alliance
second I have uh just met with pastor
daduan and and of course we discussed
also how we can make progress on the on
the accession of Finland and Sweden and
we agreed to restart the talks to
convene a meeting in in Brussels at the
NATO headquarters with Finland Sweden
and and turkey
and and we need also to understand that
so far this has been the quickest
accession process in NATO's modern
history
Finland and Sweden applied in May last
year already in June 30 allies also
turkey decided to invite them and we
also all 30 allies agreed including
turkey on the accession protocols and
all Factory allies have signed these
accession protocols then
28 out of the third allies so this
rectified in the National parliaments
the Hungarian Parliament has been
declare that they will start the
accession process also the discussions
and the decisions last in the next week
and then
on on Finland and Sweden
I cannot guarantee you any specific date
but on Finland turkey has made it clear
that they don't see any problems with
ratification
with Sweden there are some issues Still
Remains higher Medicaid at both Finland
and Sweden have lived up to their
commitments they
signed up to at the NATO Summit last
year so I think the time has come to
eratify both of them now but of course
turkey has no the position and then we
have this trilateral mechanism to
address how to how to ensure that that
the accession process continues to move
forward and and the most important thing
is not whether Finland swin joins
exactly at the same time the most
important thing is that join as soon as
possible you can briefly add one more
thing and that is that we need to also
understand that Finland and Sweden are
not to different place now they're much
more secure now than before they applied
because as part of the accession process
they have now been integrated more and
more into NATO civilian and Military
structures
defense planning capability targets we
exercise more together Nature's
increases presence different allies are
also provided bilateral security
assurances so it's absolutely
inconceivable that Finland or Sweden
will be faced with any military threats
from Russia without NATO reacting so we
are making a lot of progress we have
come a long way already and I'm
confident I will also Finance this
process
so and time for final question please
James Bays from Al Jazeera Secretary
General I've already asked you this once
this week but please can you tell us
what evidence you have that China is
giving is thinking of giving weapons to
Russia and to all three of you I know
this is the final question so very
quickly and directly you're here for
estonia's Independence but what message
directly to President Putin do you want
to send today about Ukraine's
Independence
well
um we are monitoring closely what China
is doing uh and we have seen signs that
they may be considering and planning to
send a little late to Russia this will
be a very big mistake this is very
serious and that's for that's also why
the United States and other allies have
conveyed so clearly that this should not
happen then briefly on the message to
Moscow the message Moscow is that
President Putin started this War
President Putin can end this war today
by redoing drawing his forces if he
doesn't do that we will stand by Ukraine
for as long as it takes and allies have
provided unprecedented level of Military
Support to Ukraine because this is about
Ukraine it will be a tragedy if
President Putin wins for the ukrainians
but will be dangerous for all of us and
therefore this is in our own security
interest to ensure that Ukraine prevails
territorial Integrity but also for
Universal values and these are the
values of
peace
respect for the international law
respect for the U.N Charter and
therefore Ukraine is not only fighting
for its independence but also for all of
us
and we will stand by Ukraine for as long
as it takes we have shown resilience
unity and determination during the last
12 months and President Putin can bet on
the fact that this will be doubled down
in resolve unity and determination to
stand by Ukraine
yes um
we are united as shown and we are united
behind Ukraine and Russia can't win this
war so sooner Russia realizes that this
aggression was a mistake the better to
everybody thank you
so thank you everyone this concludes the
press conference thank you for attending
thank you for following online have a
great afternoon